[Music]
it's a Saturday night in Toronto a
concrete
jungle towering buildings and constant
[Music]
traffic hundreds descending on public
space for a new kind of urban ritual
we're going to be going on a journey
that is part meditation part Festival
part Dance Part
play
[Music]
the night is Guided by this Duo Lisa
beluch and Michelle chaet are artists
and designers known as nocturnal
medicine and we're working on creating
the kinds of Social and cultural
infrastructure that we need in order to
address emotional um and spiritual
aspects of climate
change here in this space they're giving
people a chance to reflect and unwind
from the terrifying truths of our time
it's part of a conversation we're
starting to have not about what to do
about climate change but about what it
is doing to us we're talking about
forest fires we're talking about
droughts and deaths these are heavy
topics they're really big they're really
painful and for ions of people they're
also a wakeup call across the planet
record-breaking destruction defined a
summer of climate reality Canada's worst
Wildfire season July was the hottest
month on record Mass evacuations by Road
and by
air so we see it in the news we see the
smoke we're breathing in the smoke and
yet we don't live in a society that is
reflecting these changes and and that's
really twisted
actually far from the big city in this
remote place thousands of kilometers
away people rely on the changing
seasons but Labrador is among the places
warming roughly three times faster than
the rest of the world here they're no
strangers to this Doom and Gloom the
emotions of this summer I think have
been so complex for people where you see
how much people actually care but how
much people have suffered and how much
has been
lost Ashley consolo is the vice Provo of
the labrador Campus of Memorial
University and the founding dean of the
school of Arctic and subarctic studies
Ashley has spent decades researching how
changes to our environmental world are
intrinsically linked with changes in our
mental and emotional health whether
people were directly affected and
evacuated or people who have been
watching like you could really see it
this almost Collective grief indigenous
languages have phrases to describe this
but it was only in 2018 when Ashley and
a colleague introduced a new English
term in an academic Journal ecological
grief whether it's an individual animal
whether it's an ecosystem a habitat a
body of water a forest large scale
climate shifts anything that is changing
around us that is causing an emotional
reaction particularly grief if you can
name something that resonates with
people then that takes it from the
individual to the collective and can
actually be a very empowering thing for
someone who's experiencing the the
sadness and the loss and the grief
around climate
change mourning the change of what was
and what could be Eco grief comes and
cascading waves one thing leading to
another to another to another and then a
lot of people just said look it's grief
Without End like everywhere I look
there's something to grieve like many
Concepts in mental health e grief is a
way to understand real
feelings it's also a rational and normal
and reasonable response to feel badly
about it because people will start to
feel bad and they're like oh I'm just
silly like there's something about us
that is not allowing us to go it's okay
that I feel this way and of course I
would feel this way and this is actually
a really healthy
response sharing those emotions and our
connection to the Earth is something
Elder Duke Redbird of the soine First
Nation does through poet
I've gone around the Sun 84
times and in that time I learned a
little wisdom if the universe were a
church or a temple or a
synagogue then Mother Earth is an altar
his work reflects a relationship in many
Colonial views there is a hierarchy to
life on this planet nature exists
separately or beneath us as as human
beings but for indigenous peoples we are
part of the natural world there isn't
that binary of environment ecology
ecosystem is over there and I'm over
here and I'm grieving this thing over
here it's like you're part of that
you're part of that natural world the
grief is intensely um personal Deborah
McGregor is in a shab from White Fish
River First Nation a community along the
shores of lake hiron in Ontario
she's an associate professor at osid
Hall law school and Canada Research
chair in indigenous environmental
justice like some people talk about the
climate change is is really
communication that of the earth to us
saying um this is what happens when you
do this have you noticed more people
speaking about Eco grief in the recent
years they're probably not calling it
Eco grief because it's just
grief it's loss it's intergenerational
trauma it's trauma to the Natural World
itself and the way indigenous cultures
frame this is in stories passed on
through
generations while you go back to even
the innc um creation destruction and
Recreation story so there's destruction
usually that destruction comes because
people are misbehaving very badly to
each other and the natural world which I
guess we could say is happening now it's
almost like what people are calling
crisis and disaster why are we so
surprised of course that's going to
happen by what's happening to the
Earth e grief is a symptom of this loss
Deborah says it gives us a starting
point to manage how we feel when you get
bombarded with news all the time of a
crisis narrative crisis narrative crisis
narrative it's really hard to get
excited about um what's going to happen
50 years from now what am I going to be
able to do EOG grief names what people
are feeling so I think it's an important
concept um especially for young people
cuz now they need to see a
future my youngest is almost 14 and
he'll talk all the time about the
emotional Legacy before it used to be
the talk about you've left a climate
crisis which we absolutely have but now
it's like my generation has left an
emotional burden and an emotional crisis
on them and I find that
shift really
heartbreaking
it's been 5 years since Ashley's paper
naming ecological grief was published
she says it won't be long before we
start seeing efforts dedicated to
helping people go through this and we're
seeing it in National assessments so
whether it's by Health Canada or Natural
Resources Canada that people are
starting to see the importance and
starting to realize that this is
actually a serious Global issue the
human emotion is such an important part
and often very overlooked in in the
climate discussions and in climate
action as well we all love our home it's
the narrative that runs through Ashley's
work in hundreds of conversations when I
think about ecological grief I do think
about the other side I think about the
joy the love the resilience the beauty
the communion so going outside and
trying to find the beauty and trying to
find the joy like there is even if it's
something really small or something
catches my eye or the way the the
sunlight comes off leaves there is
something Underneath It All That is this
this reminder of our capacity to feel
and our capacity to love and our
capacity to be
human